amber Riley and Ricki Lake are stopping
by this week's crazy ex-girlfriend and
only et was on set to find out how the
CW smash landed such dreamy guest stars
well god I'm Ricky was just a fan which
is the most flattering thing ever and I
believe amber was a fan too and you know
I think that we needed some this is a
kick-ass Motown number we just needed
the most kick-ass people that we could
think of and it's gonna be so fun I like
to think that I'm the number one fan I
would have mopped the floor to be a part
of this you know I would have done
anything and so they they gave me this
little dream sequence it's a little
mock-up on dream girls I'm a dream ghost
I get to wear some crazy wig later and
it's just it's um I'm tickled to be here
I am dream ghost number two I don't know
how she died we actually don't know if
she's a hallucination or ghost that is
the lyric so I don't know if we're ever
gonna figure that out but it is it's a
lot of fun though and we're starting on
an airplane which is the worst lighting
possible and then transforming it into
the kind of this beautiful dreamy stage
Motown lighting so I think that
transition of stark to beautiful will be
really fun to see
crazy ex-girlfriend